that debilitating inevitability that you
know Magnus is going to find the best
moves you reach a point and you just
know that you've lost the thread and no
matter what you do magnets will see the
correct path forward Rook B7 threatening
Rook B8 check
and Bishop G2 Rook returns captures G7
with a fork on the rook and the bishop
Vincent might resign here
yes you basically have to design
no matter how much it hurts there is
nothing you can do
we can all sympathize with the pain the
pain is immense the pain of knowing that
you had that chance it was right there
but it's up to the greats and to the
chess professionals to push that pain
away it's a 1-1 score they're gonna play
a tiebreaker tomorrow and there's the
handshake Magnus Carlson wins on demand
he defeats Vincent kymer after his loss
yesterday with a beautiful end game
display
and takes this match to what is going to
be an incredible tiebreaker tomorrow